welcome back spring is here which means
we are all in need of a good spring
cleaning and that's how Zerorez the
sponsors of today's segment can help
welcome back to our friend of the show
Ben McKee so great to see you Ben
absolutely thanks for being here let's
talk about spring it's an important time
year round to be clean but especially
spring cleaning why is spring so
important to make sure you're doing the
stuff right well I don't know if you
lived through like yesterday and all the
wind but apparently I know I almost blew
away yesterday and that's why it's a
great time of year to clean all this
dust and all this danders blowing around
get your carpets clean it's going to
help improve the indoor air quality of
your home or your business and we even
clean air ducts too so wow you guys do
it all yeah you do it all you come into
the house and take care of everything
and what I love about what you guys do
tell us about the solutions and what you
guys use it's really unlike anyone else
it is if you look at the history of
carpet cleaning it hasn't changed like
80 to 90 years people are still putting
down soaps and surfactants in their
carpet that's why your spots come back
that's why your carpet's dry crunchy uh
at zero res we clean with what we call
ZR water it eliminates the soap it'll
eliminates a headache of having crunchy
carpets and it can even out clean the
soap and detergent-based cleaners out
there yeah we definitely don't want
crunchy carpet but I want to see this up
close and personal you guys always have
the best demos it's hard to believe that
you can get this to clean
and with zero rest our goal is to get
your carpet back to a like new state
um here we go now obviously we can't
reverse the wear and tear that happens
uh when we figure out how to weave new
carpet fibers in there we'll let you
know but for now we're getting rid of
the dirt the grease and the grime and
you get to tell it's almost effortless
with our system and you guys I mean you
have been around for a while you
received the top tier Awards why do you
think your customers keep coming back
they love you guys yeah they do love us
we've been in Vegas for nearly 20 years
our cleaning is amazing but our real
asset is our team yeah we train our team
day in and day out um a mortgage is
technical knowledge of carpet cleaning
but also just how to be good
communicators how to provide the best
customer experience and that's why we
have over like 7 000 reviews online
right now incredible you guys really do
it all and we're seeing the carpet here
firsthand but do you guys work on other
materials in the house as well we do we
can clean your tile and grout we have a
whole dedicated commercial crew to work
day and night under Casino or hotel so
whatever you got just give us a call
yeah well if you
bugs wear and tear on the carpet should
they just give you a call and you guys
will come out absolutely call us visit
us online and we'll get you scheduled
well thank you so much for being here
and you guys are always have the best
demos it's hard to believe you can find
a carpet this dirty and make it that
clean so I'm always amazed by you guys
all right all the information on your
screen thank you again to Zerorez for
sponsoring this segment you can check
out their spring cleaning special clean
for as low as 35 dollars per room plus
receive free tile cleaning 100 square
feet you can call
702-840-3333 or you can visit them
online at
zerorezlasvegas.com minimums apply Las
Vegas now we'll be right back